salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
aujourd'hui je vous embarque dans le
Triangle des Bermudes il s'y passe des
choses bizarres depuis 1945 une centaine
de bateaux et une vingtaine d'avions si
son volatilisés alors certains ils
voient l'ombre des extraterrestres
d'autres évoquent des phénomènes
paranormaux enfilez votre gilet de
sauvetage j'ai peut-être une explication
à vous donner
je te montre dans les eaux troubles nous
sommes complètement perdus Navy dépêche
aussitôt deux hydravions de secours mais
là encore l'expédition vire au cauchemar
un seul engin rentre à la base l'autre
explosant vol il fait nuit sur
l'Atlantique et plus aucune nouvelle de
l'escadrille numéro 19 durant des
semaines des dizaines d'hommes et
d'avions sont envoyés sur place à la
recherche d'un lys des 5 avions
bombardiers et de l'hydravion on ne
retrouvera rien pas encore pas un débrie
le bilan est lourd 27 personnes sont
déclarées officiellement disparus
l'événement fait la une des journaux
avec une question qui revient sans cesse
où est passé l'escadrille numéro 19
l'armée est incapable de donner la
moindre explication l'enquête officielle
se contente de pointer la responsabilité
de Charles Taylor qui n'aurait pas su
prendre les bonnes décisions
puis le temps passe et cette sombre
histoire tombe dans les oubliettes
jusqu'en 1964 ou Vincent gavisse un
journaliste américain relance l'affaire
intrigué par le sort des militaires et
de leurs avions il mène sa propre
enquête et à sa grande surprise il ne
tarde pas à découvrir que l'escadrille
numéro 19 est loin d'être la seule à
s'être
volatilisée dans ce secteur ce secteur
le voici il s'agit d'une zone qui relie
l'archipel des Bermudes Miami et Porto
Rico que vous pouvez le constater elle
forme un triangle du navire à vapeur
américain SS photopaxi qui sombre corset
bien en 1925 à la destruction en vol
d'une vingtaine d'appareils plus de 100
disparitions dans les airs et en mer ont
eu lieu à l'intérieur de cette zone
géographique en un siècle Christophe
Colomb lui-même avait signalé dans son
journal de bord le comportement anormal
de ces boussoles à cet endroit
pour Vincent Gadis ce n'est pas le fruit
du hasard il pense que ce triangle
d'environ un million de kilomètres
carrés deux fois la France est très
dangereux pour toute personne qui s'y
aventure et il lui donne un nom le
Triangle des Bermudes c'est le point de
départ d'une des plus grandes énigmes du
20e siècle elle va alimenter tous les
fantasmes
ces mystérieuses disparitions intriguant
particuliers Charles Berlitz un écrivain
américain à succès passionné de
phénomènes paranormaux en 1974 il publie
The bermuda triangle je ne traduis pas
il s'agit d'un ouvrage qui recueille les
témoignages de personnes ayant survécu à
des catastrophes à l'intérieur de la
zone sur la base de ces témoignages elle
écrivain élabore une théorie ce
phénomène serait lié à la présence d'une
pyramide de Pierre engloutie dans les
profondeurs du triangle il s'agirait des
vestiges d'une civilisation vieille de
12000 ans l'édifice exercerait une
attraction sur les avions et les navires
la thèse séduit un français le célèbre
apnéiste Jacques Mayol vous savez c'est
celui dont l'histoire est racontée dans
le film Le Grand Bleu du coup
Jacques Mayol décide de se rendre sur
place pour vérifier la théorie de
Berlitz il plonge malheureusement il
rentre bredouille d'autres avancent des
hypothèses encore plus loufoques comme
la présence d'une porte sous-marine
ouverte sur une autre dimension ou bien
l'existence d'un monstre géant capable
d'inspirer les navires au fond de
l'océan enfin la thèse la plus farfelue
est toujours très populaire aujourd'hui
cette disparition serait due à des
extraterrestres vivants dans les
profondeurs
mais vous l'avez compris tout au long
des années 70-80 l'ouvrage provoque une
véritable fascination autour du Triangle
des Bermudes qu'on tarde pas à
rebaptiser le trio du diable ou encore
le triangle maudit à la même époque
cependant le gouvernement américain
tente de calmer les esprits au milieu
des années 70 on envoie sur place une
commission d'enquête pour étudier les
causes des différentes disparitions la
conclusion est sans appel Jack
volatilisation ce sont les termes de
l'armée serait dû soit la météo soit des
problèmes techniques à bord des avions
bref il n'y aurait aucun mystère autour
du Triangle des Bermudes côté météo on
incrimine les cyclones tropicaux il
sévise dans la région de juin à novembre
et suivent un trajet bien précis
au-dessus de l'océan Atlantique les
scientifiques l'appellent l'aller des
ouragans et bien il se trouve que le
triangle se situe en plein milieu
lorsqu'ils arrivent à sa hauteur leur
force est terrifiante l'oeil du cyclone
peut atteindre plus de 1000 km de
diamètre et les vents dépassent parfois
250 km/h mais ceci ne peut pas expliquer
la disparition de l'escadrille numéro 19
souvenez-vous elle s'est volatilisée au
mois de décembre 1945 en plein hiver
alors les météorologues avancent une
autre hypothèse la saison froide qui
s'étend de des jamais produit elle aussi
son lot de perturbations bien moins
prévisible on les surnomme les bombes ce
sont des tempêtes brèves et
ultra-violes qui se déclenchent d'un
instant à l'autre dans un ciel qui
jusque là était d'un bleu azur c'est
peut-être l'une d'entre elles qui
auraient englouti les avions et leurs
équipages le 5 décembre 1945 à l'origine
de ce piège le golf stream ce courant
chaud bien connu traverse le Triangle
des Bermudes le contraste entre ce
courant chaud les eaux de l'océan
froides et les masses d'air tout aussi
fraîches pendant l'hiver forme un
cocktail explosif qui engendre des vents
très violents et des pluies
torrentielles c'est aussi à lui que l'on
attribue la formation de vagues immenses
que l'on appelle les vagues scélérates
elle grimpe il y a 30 mètres de hauteur
et pourrait être responsable d'une
naufrage de nombreux navires mais aussi
séduisante soit-elle ces différentes
hypothèses ne font pas l'unanimité dans
la communauté scientifique alors on
continue de chercher de nouvelles
explications
et si la cause de ces mystérieuses
disparitions étaient tout simplement
d'origine magnétique c'est la vie de
certains scientifiques qui soulignent
qu'à l'intérieur du triangle les
boussoles se mettent parfois à tourner
sans raison au point de désorienter les
marins en suivant cette piste il
finissent par identifier un responsable
la roche volcanique gorgée de magnétique
qui s'étale sur plus de 200 km sous le
plancher océanique à cet endroit la plus
grande concentration de magnétique se
trouve dans la zone du triangle cette
nouvelle hypothèse pourrait expliquer le
naufrage des bateaux mais aussi
l'épargne qui surviennent sur les
instruments de bord dans les avions mais
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là en 2015
une nouvelle explication voit le jour le
coupable serait le méthane d'importantes
poches de ce gaz se trouve dans le
sous-sol à l'aplomb du triangle suite à
des mouvements de terrain le gaz serait
libéré et remonterait à la surface
jusque dans une atmosphère intoxiquant
au passage les pilotes des avions
naviguant dans la zone la présence de ce
gaz modifie également la densité de
l'eau les navires ne peuvent plus
flotter dessus il coule tous ceux qui
ont disparu aurait donc été
entraînés par le faux voilà où nous en
sommes aujourd'hui alors les savons
ont-ils définitivement percé le mystère
pas sûr car cette hypothèse ne convainc
pas tout le monde le redoutable Triangle
des Bermudes n'a sans doute pas encore
livré tous ces secrets j'aime bien
l'aventure mais pas sûr que jaillit
passer des vacances j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner
et si vous aimez ce genre d'histoire
dites le moi en commentaire j'en ai
plein les tiroirs à très bientôt les
epicurios et les épicurieux
[Applaudissements]